SIX DAYS AGO, RUSSIA'S VLADIMIR
PUTIN SOUGHT TO SHAKE THE VERY
FOUNDATIONS OF THE FREE WORLD.
THINKING HE COULD MAKE IT BEND
TO HIS MENACING WAYS.
BUT HE BADLY MISCALCULATED.
HE THOUGHT HE COULD ROLL INTO
UKRAINE AND THE WORLD WOULD ROLL
OVER.
INSTEAD, HE MET WITH A WALL OF
STRENGTH HE NEVER ANTICIPATED OR
IMAGINED.
HE MET THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY -- TO EVERY
UKRAINIAN, THEIR FEARLESSNESS,
THEIR COURAGE, THEIR
DETERMINATION LITERALLY INSPIRES
THE WORLD.
GROUPS OF CITIZENS BLOCKING
TANKS WITH THEIR BODIES.
EVERYONE FROM STUDENTS TO
RETIREES TO TEACHERS TURNED
SOLDIERS, DEFENDING THEIR
HOMELAND.
AND IN THIS STRUGGLE,
PREDZELENSKYY SAID IN A SPEECH
TO THE EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT,
LIGHT WILL WIN OVER DARKNESS.
UKRAINIAN AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED STATES IS HERE TONIGHT
SITTING WITH THE FIRST LADY.
LET'S EACH OF US IF YOU'RE ABLE
TO STAND, STAND AND SEND AN
UNMISTAKABLE SIGNAL TO THE
WORLD, TO UKRAINE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
BRIGHT, STRONG, RESOLVED.
YES.
WE THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
STAND WITH THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY, WE HAVE
LEARNED THIS LESSON.
WHEN DICTATORS DO NOT PAY A
PRICE FOR THEIR AGGRESSION, THEY
CAUSE MORE CHAOS.
THEY KEEP MOVING.
AND THE COST, THE THREATS TO
AMERICA AND TO THE WORLD, KEEPS
RISING.
THAT'S WHY THE NATO ALLIANCE WAS
CREATED, TO SECURE PEACE AND
STABILITY IN EUROPE AFTER WORLD
WAR II.
THE UNITED STATES IS A MEMBER
ALONG WITH 29 OTHER NATIONS.
IT MATTERS.
AMERICAN DIPLOMACY MATTERS.
AMERICAN RESOLVE MATTERS.
PUTIN'S LATEST ATTACK ON UKRAINE
WAS PREMEDITATED AND TOTALLY
UNPROVOKED.
HE REJECTED REPEATED, REPEATED
EFFORTS AT DIPLOMACY.
HE THOUGHT THE WEST AND NATO
WOULDN'T RESPOND.
HE THOUGHT HE COULD DIVIDE US AT
HOME IN THIS CHAMBER AND THIS
NATION.
HE THOUGHT HE COULD DIVIDE US IN
EUROPE AS WELL.
BUT PUTIN WAS WRONG.
WE ARE READY.
WE ARE UNITED, AND THAT'S WHAT
WE DID.
WE STAYED UNITED.
WE PREPARED EXTENSIVELY AND
CAREFULLY.
WE SPENT MONTHS BUILDING
COALITIONS OF OTHER FREEDOM
LOVING NATIONS IN EUROPE AND THE
AMERICAS, FOR AMERICA TO THE
ASIAN AND AFRICAN CONTINENTS TO
CONFRONT PUTIN.
LIKE MANY OF YOU, I SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS UNIFYING OUR
EUROPEAN HOURS.
WE SHARED WITH THE WORLD IN
ADVANCE WHAT WE KNEW PUTIN WAS
PLANNING.
AND PRECISELY HUE HE WOULD TRY
TO FALSIFY AND JUSTIFY HIS
AGGRESSION.
WE COUNTERED RUSSIA'S LIES WITH
THE TRUTH, AND NOW, NOW THAT
HE'S ACTED, THE FREE WORLD IS
HOLDING HIM ACCOUNTABLE ALONG
WITH 27 MEMBERS OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION, INCLUDING FRANCE,
GERMANY
ITALY AS JAPAN, KOREA, NEW
ZEALAND, AND MANY OTHERS, EVEN
SWITZERLAND ARE INFLICTING PAIN
ON RUSSIA AND SUPPORTING THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE.
PUTIN IS NOW ISOLATED FROM THE
WORLD MORE THAN HE HAS EVER
BEEN.
TOGETHER --
[ APPLAUSE ]
TOGETHER, ALONG WITH OUR ALLIES,
WE'RE RIGHT NOW ENFORCING
POWERFUL ECONOMIC SANCTIONS.
WE'RE CUTTING OFF RUSSIA'S
LARGEST BANKS AND INTERNATIONAL
FINANCE SYSTEM.
PREVENTING RUSSIA'S CENTRAL BANK
FROM DEFENDING THE RUSSIAN
RUBLE.
MAKING PUTIN $630 BILLION WAR
FUND WORTHLESS.
WE'RE CHOKING RUSSIA'S ACCESS --
WE'RE CHOKING RUSSIA'S ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL SAP THE
ECONOMIC STRENGTH AND WEAKEN ITS
MILITARY FOR YEARS TO COME.
TONIGHT, I SAY TO THE RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS AND CORRUPT LEADERS
WHO BUILT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OFF THIS VIOLENT REGIME, NO
MORE.
THE UNITED STATES --
[ APPLAUSE ]
I MEAN IT.
THE UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS ASSEMBLING A
DEDICATED TASK FORCE TO GO AFTER
THE CRIMES OF THE RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS.
WE'RE JOINING WITH EUROPEAN
ALLIES TO FIND AND SEIZE THEIR
YACHTS, THEIR LUXURY APARTMENTS,
THEIR PRIVATE JETS.
WE'RE COMING FOR YOUR ILL
BEGOTTEN GAINS AND TONIGHT I'M
ANNOUNCING THAT WE WILL JOIN OUR
ALLIES IN CLOSING OFF AMERICAN
AIR SPACE TO ALL RUSSIAN
FLIGHTS, FURTHER ISOLATING
RUSSIA AND ADDING ADDITIONAL
SQUEEZE ON THEIR ECONOMY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
HE HAS NO IDEA WHAT'S COMING.
THE RUBLE HAS ALREADY LOST 30%
OF ITS VALUE.
RUSSIAN STOCK MARKET HAS LOST
40% OF ITS VALUE.
AND TRADING REMAINS SUSPENDED.
RUSSIAN ECONOMY IS REELING, AND
PUTIN ALONE IS THE ONE TO BLAME.
TOGETHER WITH OUR ALLIES, WE'RE
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO THE
UKRAINIANS IN THEIR FIGHT FOR
FREEDOM.
MILITARY ASSISTANCE, ECONOMIC
ASSISTANCE.
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE.
WE'RE GIVING MORE THAN A BILLION
DOLLARS OF DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO
UKRAINE AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO
AID UKRAINIAN PEOPLE AS THEY
DEFEND THEIR COUNTRY AND HELP
EASE THEIR SUFFERING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
BUT LET ME BE CLEAR.
OUR FORCES ARE NOT ENGAGED AND
WILL NOT ENGAGE WITH THE RUSSIAN
FORCES IN UKRAINE.
OUR FORCES ARE NOT GOING TO
EUROPE TO FIGHT UKRAINE BUT TO
DEFEND OUR NATO ALLIES IN THE
EVENT PUTIN DECIDES TO KEEP
MOVING WEST.
FOR THAT PURPOSE, WE HAVE
MOBILIZED AMERICAN GROUND
FORCES, AIR SQUADRONS, SHIP
DEPLOYMENTS TO PROTECT LATVIA,
LITHUANIA, AND ESTONIA.
AS I HAVE MADE CRYSTAL CLEAR,
THE UNITED STATES AND OUR ALLIES
WILL DEFEND EVERY INCH OF
TERRITORY THAT IS NATO TERRITORY
WITH A FULL FORCE OF OUR
COLLECTIVE POWER.
EVERY SINGLE INCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND WE'RE CLEAR EYED.
UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING BACK
WITH PURE COURAGE.
BUT THE NEXT FEW DAYS, WEEKS,
AND MONTHS WILL BE HARD ON THEM.
PUTIN HAS UNLEASHED VIOLENCE AND
CHAOS, BUT WHILE HE MAY MAKE
GAINS ON THE BATTLEFIELD, HE'LL
PAY A CONTINUING HIGH PRICE OVER
THE LONG RUN.
AND A POUND OF UKRAINIAN PEOPLE,
PROUD, PROUD PEOPLE, POUND FOR
POUND, READY TO FIGHT WITH EVERY
INCH THEY HAVE.
THEY HAVE KNOWN 30 YEA